in regard to like the civil war stuff
though i think it's actually i'm
extremely optimistic because i think
it's a good thing that one of the top
issues that we care about and have to
deal with in our country is abortion
instead of hunger or crazy inflation or
actual i mean
i hate using the word privilege but it's
a relatively privileged position to have
this the top issue you care about and to
make a joke from earlier maybe we might
need to not blame those russians for the
war crimes in ukraine because they were
propagandized so heavily well no by the
russians to deny
there's an interesting question i'm
rejecting i reject the premise so the
obviously but this is the war that the
wars that we're involved in now i know
people who fought in those wars they
were propagandized as young men to
believe that going to the middle east
and quote unquote fighting for our
freedom was the right thing to do they
ended up doing things over there that
they very much regret but i would not
charge them with murder sure i i think
it would you because would you know
because you scoff at this idea that
being propagandized means that you
shouldn't be held accountable there's a
difference between trying to liberate
the iraqi people and then the war crimes
also committed by certain soldiers on
the ground so if you're on the ground
and massacring people even if you are a
us soldier you should be penalized
because that's not what our army teaches
you i would agree and we do by the way
and also the thing is uh with the iraq
war the iraq war we have the benefit of
it handling poorly and that's why we get
to look back at it so poorly but you
know if the if we were able to set up
the problem with iraq is that we weren't
able to set up a democracy there after
so
there's a lot i didn't ask about work i
didn't ask about things that our nation
would consider war crimes and that our
country's a guest is against in terms of
its policy i'm talking about the united
states being involved in illegitimate
wars where people died i would say
they're legitimate i wouldn't call them
a legitimate you wouldn't call them
legitimate even though congress didn't
declare them well the congress hasn't
declared a war since world war two am i
calling every war since world war ii
illegitimate
no well why not they didn't go through
the well because the process well we
don't do a lot of things by the
constitution the congress is the first
thing that's mentioned in our
constitution but you know they barely
have actual power and as much as i'd
like to be a constitutionalist in
practice de facto we have a
commander-in-chief and he's the person
who makes the foreign policy and in our
current world that's the way it needs to
be we can't have our president be
strapped by congress congress can again
we might not have gotten involved in two
20-year long wars that yeah but the
senate countless suffering and the
senate kicks off anytime the senate the
senate in congress is extremely
indecisive and they would get nothing
done we need a leader to be able to act
freely and quickly on the world stage in
my opinion i think also i'm very hawkish
i think most of these wars are justified
i don't want to get involved with
ukraine because i want to be focused on
the chinese though so that's why i would
justify a lot of these wars not the war
crimes though there is some leniency in
times of war and i understand things get
crazy but as war crimes is a completely
different thing and we do prosecute
americans who commit war crimes yeah and
and i never said we didn't and i never
said that we shouldn't if someone
commits a war crime they should
absolutely be prosecuted and i think we
just plain don't see eye to eye on the
powers of the presidency the executive
branch and whether we should have been
involved in any of these disasters it
feels like people do overlook the war
because i was joking originally about
the russians i do feel like ukraine's
getting a little bit more extra scrutiny
on their obvious military propaganda
than russia does we like to talk about
how corrupt ukraine is which given it is
corrupt but the most corrupt [ __ ] on
planet earth is actually russia so do
you know what i'm talking about there
with the given a little bit more slack
to russia than ukraine
i'm not as sure on that but i would
agree with you that when you're looking
at that situation i mean i i don't have
a dog in that fight frankly
well that's part of why i don't want to
see the united states government get
involved at all even if there's a
country that i would say is more likely
to be in the right i wouldn't say that
the united states should go defend them
or fight for them oh so you think even
if the country is in the right we
shouldn't assist and defend that it
depends on whether it's a struggle that
there are certain instances where it
might be necessary for us to be involved
do you think zolensky is heroic for
defending his homeland and supposedly
choosing not to leave and continuing to
fight instead of surrendering i think
yeah yeah i would think that that's
probably a good thing for a foreign
leader to do to stay in their country
and fight if someone's invading do you
think we should be sending weapons to
ukraine
no i don't think the united states
government should be involved at all to
be honest okay but then otherwise it
literally just falls to russia should we
let should we not let our allies abroad
know that we have their back in any
capacity well ukraine isn't a part of
nato and that's part of why they're
having this entire conflict i don't
think it's the united states
responsibility to ensure that nato or
that uh ukraine doesn't fall to russia
sure are you worried that any other
countries will get a hint and a wink and
a nod from the u.s withdrawing from the
global world stage as much are you
scared i think thank you other conflicts
is what i'm getting well what i think is
much more of a serious risk is the fact
that we have spent the last 20 years
involved in foreign conflicts in the
middle east and they all ended
disastrously and what we showed other
countries is that we're not serious
about fighting the wars that we do want
to fight in the long term because we
don't get involved i i think overall the
united states
even if you want to have this more
hawkish approach and say we want to be
more taken more seriously on the foreign
stage we want to show our enemies that
we're not weak
i think
a to get the american people on board
with that after you have just completely
failed in your foreign policy in
basically every major respect is going
to be impossible even if you think that
we should or would make us look good on
the foreign stage i mean that trust has
just been completely lost and i would
also say yeah sure i want to ask you
this one last thing this is what like
foreign policy people say that if we
didn't stand at all with ukraine that
china would get like a winking nod that
we're not willing to defend taiwan i
wanted to ask you what do you think
about that argument and also should we
defend or supply taiwan with weapons
because that's the next step that's the
next ukraine that's the next conflict i
think that's a really good question so
part of the reason ukraine has been such
a disaster in my estimation is that
our white house and joe biden our
intelligence agencies you know the um
the war machine was basically saying
they believed that
that uh russia was going to invade and
then there were no precautions taken so
i think if we had established a no-fly
zone prior to them invading that could
have deterred them from even more
well i'm not necessarily saying that we
should do that but i am saying
i don't think so because i think russia
invades anyway and then if you knocked
out if nato calls a no-fly zone and then
russia invades and then they shoot down
a jet that's still
world war three and as my yeah no it
absolutely could be uh if we're talking
about taiwan specifically though i'd
have to look at the situation i don't i
don't have a set position there i do
understand your concerns that if they
get taiwan that's a big problem for us
um i i looked up the best data i could
possibly find on this issue
abortion doesn't weigh particularly
heavily for either party but there's a
plus five republican
percentage so when it comes to the issue
of abortion republicans at 28 percent
view it as a top issue democrats at 23
and independence at 25. so republicans
do have the plus five that is to say
when all of these changes are happening
with abortion it doesn't seem like it
will be the biggest motivating factor
but it will it will be more likely to
motivate republicans than it would
democrats it's interesting that climate
change is up top there yeah did you see
republicans it's eight percent
but it's interesting because um did you
see there was some data that came out
from okay cupid and tinder that if you
don't care about climate change it's a
deal-breaker
the ladies are not going to go out with
you as a matter of fact they came up
with this term petro-masculinity
to describe the combination of um
of the man who is uh you know of course
racist but uh is anti-climate is racist
is nationalist and is misogynist so if
you don't think that uh climate change
is a super big issue then you're
apparently petro-masculine and this is a
problem i care about climate change as
much as barack obama does i'm going to
buy my beachfront property and i'm going
to relax
yeah
i liked it because the other thing too
is the the data didn't say that the
person that you're interested in had to
um
be interested in
taking any action on climate change or
doing anything it was just if you care
about it like if you really feel deeply
about it and make sure you bring your
recycled bag to the market when you buy
your foie gras or whatever
does it say which direction you have to
care deeply in because what if i care
about causing more climate change i like
this
my favorite part too is that nobody ever
remembers that fossil fuel actually
resulted in the greatest decrease in
global poverty the world has ever seen
and free trade shout out to that but yes
um
i love that one last thing because i
just had it on my mind
i don't think it's enough to just be
anti-communist domestically and
anti-islamist
domestically i do think that if we
believe in these values then we should
try to
export them and make sure that people
aren't attacking those values worldwide
and that's why i stand so strongly with
taiwan it's not enough to be
anti-communists back home you need to be
anti-communist internationally that's
why i stand with south korea japan
that's why we need to work closely with
australia and india we really need to
box the chinese and they are the you the
next geopolitical threat we do not want
to live in a multi-polar world where
china gets to call shots on even playing
field as us they view every part of our
system as negative and bad um we want
less of that chinese communist influence
here see i wish people would be honest
about that because uh uh i often tell
people if you like the way i i said this
about hillary clinton i'm like if you
like the status quo
you know if if you like that we get our
shirts made in indonesia if you like
that it's a nickel an hour to make your
shoes you gotta vote for hillary clinton
if you have a problem with that and war
and the international policies that
exploit foreign countries you'll want a
donald trump because he's all about
america first and wants manufacturing
here which will make things cost more
money in the long run but typically
everyone everyone's standard of living
will go up quite a bit i think i don't
think it's exploiting i think it's
helping these other countries and it's
so interesting when we talk about these
prices going up and how much people care
it's because like oh i mean hey we'll
make it domestically and then shirts
will be a little bit more expensive the
americans won't care this is coming from
the same people who constantly say oh
gas is up two more dollars joe biden's
definitely gonna lose the election
because of this so i feel like some
people are having it both ways when
they're talking about that though but do
we care about higher prices but if it's
right in america you're making a mistake
donald trump was in favor of energy
independence united states which was
lowering gas prices sure so you can
complain about joe biden's failed policy
energy policies the united states the
reason you know why we give 12 million
dollars to pakistani gender studies
to maintain the strength of the
petrodollar we want to give people money
and say use it use it it's valuable that
way they say okay i'll get something for
this
donald trump was like secure our borders
better trade deals manufacturing back
home that would have made many things
cheaper would have made some things more
expensive
all in all the quality of life for
everybody was going up we were seeing
businesses enacting 32-hour work weeks
we were seeing paid parental leave these
things were happening organically
because the economy was booming as jim
cramer's had the best number of our
lives but numbers of our lives but some
people they like the idea of for
whatever reason actually i'll put it
this way i think if you actually know
what the democrats have been doing for
30 years along with the neocons don't
get me wrong things have changed in the
past five years with republicans not too
much but a little bit
they were exporting
american wealth they were extracting
from the system
dylan radigan called it if he was
referring to the same thing
and it was resulting in american lives
being worse off for people getting angry
and there was a backlash
so if you want to export american
neoliberalism and neoconservative values
then you want to do everything you're
saying i suppose if if neo-liberal is
free trade and neo-con is you know
values are worldwide and not let our
allies get stumped then yeah they're
kind of down with it yeah that's the one
thing
that we change other countries political
structure based on what we in the united
states have determined would be
advantageous to us so when we go to the
middle east and say you know what let's
turn afghanistan into a democracy even
though it's a completely unpragmatic
goal that we could never achieve and
then we waste 20 years over there uh
trillions of dollars thousands of human
lives that's what neoconservatism is
that's what its record has been so you
can talk about defending our allies but
all we have done is gotten people killed
and made the situation worse over there
then
this is a really good point though
people don't want to live in a
multi-polar world where china is calling
the shots or at least putting people say
yeah and people don't want that
but the challenge i suppose is many
people don't want to see americans being
shipped off to foreign countries in what
is what is typically viewed as conquest
invading iraq and afghanistan for vague
or incorrect reasons for the sake of
expanding our power in these regions i
think we need to continue to support our
allies both uh militarily and
economically because in the zero-sum
game of foreign policy if it isn't us
helping out our allies it's them going
to our
what does that mean what does that mean
it means that hey if we choose not to um
be friendly to the philippines and when
china you know acts aggressively in the
south china sea and um navigates through
their waters with impunity that we need
to defend the philippines and let them
know that we have their back
okay we get that i'm talking about like
you know invading iraq and afghanistan
and firing missiles into syria
so i i mean hey if right now let's do it
into a modern day issue right now if
iran is acquiring nuclear weapons are we
going to do anything about it
why if they do should we do anything
about it why why should we do something
about it yeah why should we because i
don't think iran an autocratic islamist
regime who's threatened to wipe multiple
of our allies off the map should have
nuclear weapons what do we do about it
um well so far it's been the jco jcpoa
the iran deal that we've been like one
foot in and one foot out of and then
it's also through our proxy allies
actually it was stuxnet yeah and now we
have their centrifuges and now we have
our proxy allies too like israel who are
constantly
you know harming iran one way or another
but trying to protect the development of
the veterans to keep it to the modern
issues
would you you're you're i suppose you're
arguing in support of
the the corruption in ukraine and the
missile strikes on syria so it's not i i
hate the corruption ukraine but i think
the russia i think russia is the most
country on planet earth moreover you
know vladimir putin is a former kgb
actual soviet communist so we shouldn't
have a lot of faith in this guy and
obviously zlansky isn't a perfect figure
but i'll tell you who's a lot further
from perfect it's vladimir putin who
actually poisons his political
opposition and has committed war crimes
in the past and now what it looks like
is continuing to do so in ukraine so
like syria right the the u.s has kind of
pulled out of there and unfortunately
we're back you know thank you joe biden
as i understand like russia rules the
airspace and that's part of the reason
why israel hasn't come
as um hard out against uh russia as they
could have but i mean why how did these
jihadis and these rebels end up with um
nato-backed weapons in afghanistan in
syria in syria
we supplied some of the rebel groups
originally and the west wanted isis to
destabilize syria because we wanted to
build a gas pipeline
we want to get rid of bashar al-assad
because we want to go build a gas
pipeline there are a few reasons we want
to get rid of well the main reason is
that in 2009 the cia wanted to invade
because we were trying to build a
pipeline from qatar through syria and
turkey into europe to offset the gazprom
gas monopoly which goes through ukraine
yeah ukraine subsequently now we're
involved in a conflict in that country
because well surprise surprise joe biden
once he gets put in charge his son
happens to get a job
become a director for a gas company in
ukraine i think we want regime change
all of this is tied together we wanted
to change regime change in syria because
they were a russian ally and everything
else comes after that that's the core
issue but do you know why we wanted
regime change because they're russian
allies
because when we said we want to build a
gas pipeline to offset the russian gas
monopoly with gazprom bashar al-assad
told the united states allowing you to
do that would upset our ally russia this
was reported in the guardian back in
like 2012 the u.s wanted to invade
instead a civil war breaks out the
rebels are given nato-backed weapons and
a truck from detroit with some guy's
phone number on it which created a huge
crisis for this guy's poor company and
it was destabilizing the entire region
was the west basically being like europe
deserves cheap gas now if you like the
idea of europe having cheaper gas
because russia is gripping them by the
balls then just be honest about it that
the us is willing to destroy entire
regions and create chaos in ukraine and
syria for the sake of their allies if
you like your wealth just admit it i
think it's much bigger than just gas
going through syria i think syria has
been uh become a proxy essentially for
iran and that's why we're fighting their
multiple countries are fighting on
multiple sides it's one of the most
complica complicated conflicts in the
middle east but they're iranian proxies
and we don't want iranian proxies to win
out in syria next to our other allies
and we don't want iran to continue to
spread their influence same thing's
going on in yemen with the houthi rebels
attacking our other allies through the
saudis the saudis are backing and us
having a blockade up that starved 84 000
children to death sure again the we
haven't acted properly in all these
cases and there have been consequences
to our actions but i feel like if we're
overlooking constantly the misdeeds of
our enemies who are much greater and
larger than ours then we're really
missing the point have they starved 85
000 children to death who has are our
enemies so no don't get wrong the houthi
rebels are terrible our enemies have
done worse yeah and the houthi they're
all they're yeah
so then we should get involved and have
the united states-backed blockade that
has literally starved tens of thousands
of children to death stand even after
joe biden says we're not going to be
involved in this conflict anymore
because some people in that region also
did bad things it's a zero-sum game it
either comes down to do we want them to
be in our sphere of influence or the
iranian and uh iranian and russian and
if they if iranians and russians and
chinese continue to exert their
influence and expand this is just going
to come to bite us back in the ass
further down the line yeah i mean this
is the unit this all has to do with the
unipolar world order that the united
states currently has and i think
that's what conservatives probably
should conserve and we need to do that
by continuing to assist and support our
allies in the zero-sum game of
geopolitics if they're not with us
they're going to our enemies well i
don't believe in child sacrifice even in
the name of supporting our allies well
this is just about sacrifice come on
what is tens of thousands of children
and dying starving to the war
regardless
and we're supporting one side the
conflict is happening right now if we
didn't support ukraine the conflict
would still be happening and the
russians are still going to be
massacring people so i'll tell you the
russians have killed kids and they've
also called the united states okay okay
okay okay the united states is funding
and backing the blockade that is
starving the children that's my point if
we weren't doing that those children
would not be surprised i don't want to
go in circles because we've said that
several times my question is uh you said
the conflict would still be happening in
ukraine how come there was no conflict
in ukraine when trump was president
oh i mean because putin was scared of
trump in my opinion
yeah yeah i think he like leaders did
not were not able to predict what trump
would do
i think on the world stage people do not
respect trump and i mean do not respect
biden at all as i understand joe biden
just had his phone call ignored by
muhammad bin salman the current leader
of saudi arabia trump would not have
allowed that to happen trump the first
place that trump visited was saudi
arabia if they did anything like that
you know trump is freaking out on
twitter or something yeah or anything
and he's holding them to account saudi
money is the most influential money in
dc trump would not let that stuff slide
if trump is in office right now i think
we'd have more of our allies on a
stranglehold but i'm also conflicted
because the saudis have now become
political the saudis chose not to pump
oil to scrub
i don't want to jump around too much
think about that under donald trump we
didn't have the conflict in ukraine
putin was scared of him i agree with
that
i also think donald trump was actually
right he was crushing isis he didn't
care about syria he was like get rid of
isis whatever but but you know the the
democratic establishment the neocons and
the new libs were like let isis
destabilize assad's regime and then you
know we can come and pick up the pieces
or leave him in rubble as we build under
trump our border was more secure our
economy was way better and there was
less war
would you consider trump a neocon
no it's interesting because he his chief
of staff i forgot exactly who it was but
he's been called the neocon john bolton
well he wasn't surrounded by he
appointed
yes yes absolutely and then he also was
a big proponent of nato again he sounded
anti-nato but what he was really saying
was everybody should increase their
budget to like the percent of gdp that
they should be paying the united states
he was a close supporter of japan um for
the purposes of taiwan stood very strong
with israel so again this could be leo
though it's not that's all it's it's
it's america's first populism and and
and ending with
nato israel and japan is america first
populism under trump just
we wouldn't expect someone who's an
america first populous to walk in and be
alike as of today there's no nato
anymore he went to them and said why are
we paying your bills all these people
want to come out and brag about their oh
europe's got all this health care and
it's like how much do do we cover their
the like how many troops do we have in
germany 30 000 some ridiculous is it 30
i think it's more some ridiculous number
we're footing the bills for that trump
comes and says you got to pay us if you
want this service because he was focused
on america first i think that might be
the cost of the unipolar
world though and if that's the cost to
pay
the cost of uh being a uni the world's
soldiers that's why we have eight
aircraft carriers
he got europeans to pay yeah he got them
to pay their
yeah yeah and i'd argue that he was a
neocon because of things like that
increasing military funding and also
sending more support he was anti-war
he's anti-war through strength and
that's what i consider he got people to
pay their their bills he increased the
military funding and he also supported
our allies militarily more and i'd
considered that and the neocons and the
neolibs wanted to invade in the middle
east they liked isis destabilizing the
region instead trump had no new wars he
under his administration got the abraham
accords unprecedented peace in the
middle east there was no conflict with
ukraine the region was starting to
stabilize the economy united states was
substantially better than it ever been
but the dude just couldn't shut up to
save his own president his own his own
you know second term he couldn't save
those two congress those two senate
seats in georgia either and i had to
give back the senate to joe biden which
i feel like is an overlooked sin that
donald trump committed again this was at
the time with uh a lot of the election
fraud stuff was just bubbling yeah he
convinced people not to vote it was it
was it's i can't believe how remarkably
stupid that was yeah and now he's
campaigning right now around the country
to continue supporting candidates who
will only say that the election was
stolen and if you back up back off that
a little bit like mo brooks did he'll
withdraw will send the endorsement too
so
well the conservatives shouldn't
shouldn't keep focusing on trump as the
main guy i think it's the status you
know i think desantis is
great i would totally throw support
behind desantis i think he's been doing
great things in florida and i think that
um you know his leadership for the rest
of the country would be incredibly
effective
parents all across the state of florida
support him his his uh anti-grooming
bill
you know as his press secretary coined
it is wildly popular across the country
with parents as well it is but it's not
even an anti-grooming bill it's just
like a minor restriction on
i mean what it says is that teachers in
grades k through 12 cannot broach topics
yeah k through 3 exactly cannot broach
uh topics of sex sexual classrooms
orientation on gender identity and
orientation it says that they can't
bring it up it says they can't have
classroom instruction not not that they
can't bring it up and they're allowed
they're allowed to bring it up they're
allowed to discuss it teachers are
allowed to go to children uh in certain
circumstances that are four four or five
years old and talk to them all about
orientation and identity they can't the
bill specifically says classroom
instruction
which is a very specific way of talking
about how you go about the class like
how you go about teaching
because they could say i'm not
instructing the kids on anything i
simply told about what me and my
boyfriend do and that's allowed and if a
child goes to a teacher and says i have
questions about something the teacher is
still allowed to talk to him about it
so the bill is for many conservatives a
half measure but the left has framed it
so dramatically as don't say gay that
many conservatives are treating it like
it actually does something that they
would like when in reality it's like
oh yeah some grades won't have
curriculum but the teachers can still
talk about it well anyway parents are in
favor of it across the country and i
think that's keeping secrets
um and it does say that if children ask
about things that they should tell their
parents i well it doesn't it doesn't say
that it says they can't tell the
students not
teachers can't tell students to withhold
information but they don't need to tell
the kids to talk to their parents no but
it says that they will talk it says that
the teachers are supposed to tell the
parents about mental physical uh
mental medical or physical issues right
but if a child goes to the teacher and
says what's trans mean the teacher can
say whatever they want and tell no one
so it's it's not this bill that it's not
an anti-grooming bill
as i understand critical race theory a
core tenant of critical race theory is
talking about like lived experiences and
although that it might evidence might
show otherwise that your lived
experiences are more valuable than
anything else and what i was trying to
get at here is that i had a gay teacher
once
it was in fifth grade um as i remember
he was a nice teacher he used to give
out candy and everything um ten years
later it came out and it was like found
that he was actually a sexual predator
and touching kids and um
that's my whole story critical race
theory lived experiences
that's that's the only thing i have to
contribute to the anti-grooming bill
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there
you